dort hören will kann man ihnen irgendwie
behindern es wäre sehr nett sie haben
wir doch einmal diesen trockenen rotwein
verkauft einfach es damals sie mit so
einer blockierten zuchten damit so
ausspricht die stadt leben da habe ich
ihnen ein spritziger italiener verkauft
na das war schon früher aber war dies in
der zeit wo sie getrunken haben sachen
kommen direkt steht sie landen jetzt weg
rissen bei dem fuß mein lieber scholli
da waren sie schon ganz unten erfülle
ich sag nur balken prünster mädchen
schreibt jahrgang 89 in der praktischen
zweiliter familien packen sie haben ja
ausschaut damals
alt und gepflegt um dich zu sagen die
wertgrenzen dabei konnte sich niemand
waschen der hände haben
wir die räumlichkeiten